i'm loud man have you ever listened to
insane clown posse
nah who that is
don't worry about it you're saying clown
possession yeah who's is this great a
rap group from the 90s
from the detroit area and they wore face
paint oh like like juggalos yeah their
fans are druggables so juggalos are fans
of the insane compost man we was in
middle school brother juggalos was the
hater fool that's what a good dog we
used to stay getting to sacramento uh
juggalos bro they probably were smoking
math and i think so i think so they used
to be chasing those [ __ ] those knives
and [ __ ] the juggalos was chasing y'all
yeah until we started playing with that
iron and [ __ ] then they had it back up
they would just be chasing them with
knives and [ __ ] on them they probably
had b.o
they probably had bad odor they probably
had bad they probably like most juggalos
that i know
don't like they were like
they're not the most they're not that
they don't shower often that's what i'm
trying to say
but they love baja blast
as much mountain dew as they can get
their hands up so i gotta drill like a
jug low and get it
it's just so you can feel it feel the
whole experience